[Applause]
you know when i moved to chicago
first because that's where i was first
at uh i was there for like the bartman
like oh [ __ ] i was there when all that i
was was waiting tables
and uh you know what's crazy so you
watch that batman espn
uh clarify what it is for everybody
what do you want to see yeah yeah this
is the guy who hartman this is the guy
that they
blame the game which by the way i i
after what they did to him i don't think
the cubs i wish
they never win ever again yeah and i
would like that town i
i mean i what they did to him is insane
to me
so real quick backstory it was game six
and chicago was i think up three two so
if they win this game
yeah they go to their first world series
in like 100 years yeah they're up
big yeah yeah on the marlins i think and
then a foul ball is hit
and whoever the cubs outfielder is he is
going to catch this
and the cubs are going to win the game
yeah a fan reaches out doesn't realize
the outfield is there he's so excited to
catch a foul ball
reaches out grabs it gets in the way the
the outfielder can't catch
cubs fan cubs fan yeah and then the
the outfielder loses his [ __ ] mind on
the fan and then the marlins come back
and win that game and then when the
series in the club zombie yeah
real quick that's right if he wasn't a
cubs fan
yeah is he dead if it's now
with the internet he's probably dead
because think about that they couldn't
really get to him like they did then
right now if it was a twitter and stuff
like that already yeah yeah
he's probably dead like they would
people would have started filming him
and tracking him like he could have
he at least was able to somewhat get
away yeah just because the internet
wasn't like it was oh i meant that day
like imagine he was a fan i guess
marlins imagine he had a marlins hat on
yeah and he disrupts the play yeah and
the saddle
part of that whole thing sorry real
quick just you know the back story i
just watched i actually watched one of
the rare baseball games ever watched
you see him the rest of the game as the
comeback is happening they keep cutting
back to him and he's just staring
straight forward
[ __ ] freaking out inside like what is
happening oh my god this is all my fault
everybody hates me yeah you're just
watching that for like
30 minutes and then whatever happened
after you can so the the ball was way in
the in the stands it wasn't
like he didn't reach out at all like the
ball was if he was if he didn't move the
ball would have hit him in the head
oh so you think that there's no way that
maybe he catches it but
it's not there's there's 50 people a
ball is coming at you you know if i
throw you something you're going to move
towards it yeah
it wasn't that insane and by the way
they were up and then they lost
yeah they so they go like that yeah yeah
it wasn't this like it wasn't he he
reached over and like he's
you know yeah boys lose having to jump
kind of in the stands maybe he catches
it maybe doesn't does it
so they booed him whatever and then uh
if you watch
the documentary he then the a woman this
that works there takes him out of the
stadium and she's like we kind of got to
go
and then people see him because now he's
been on tv
all night so people see him and they
they're like oh we gotta like get you
off the streets
because you will get killed yeah and so
the woman that works there
takes him to her apartment girl so i'm
waiting tables that night
then jake melnick's this restaurant in
chicago and so
he was like packed we're all watching it
on tv and all these chicago fans
and then uh so my a friend of mine that
worked there she goes home
well she's roommates with that girl so
how crazy it is she just goes home
bartman's on tv it's the craziest thing
in the world
and she comes home and he's sitting in
her living room
and she's like hey and then he's just
like
you know like just kind of watching the
coverage of it
this guy was such a fan he had
headphones on he was listening to the
radio yeah uh and so they might play on
the radio oh they i think they put his
address out in the paper the next day
yeah they uh in the paper i believe wow
i believe
chicago tribune i mean i wish he sued
them and where they don't exist
yeah i mean they ruined that guy never
done an interview
never tried to get anything for it
they've now they've invited him to come
back
but it's like insane but you ruined the
guy's life and then i think they sent
him a world series
ring and you're like i don't even care
about that they all these fans sent them
a ring
yeah oh they because they dude they
realize
now what happened to his house he got
like oh i mean he couldn't go to work he
had to go like
he's never been back i don't know if
he's been back to the game like he's
never but he's never done an interview
this dude is a true this guy cares about
chicago more than those
players do like they he wanted them to
win more than moises of lou
probably cares about the cubs yeah yeah
and like
you ruined this guy's life yeah and it's
like and i mean they still like it was
like 10 years later they're still
with like trout bartman ruined that game
like just the audacity
yeah to do that to a guy is insane
and i always thought that i mean they
won and i don't i
i truly didn't think i don't want him to
ever i didn't want him to win that one
what you did to that guy is enough to be
i don't get over it have you reached out
to him
to bartman yeah i am bartman
the whole time like no one knows
you